first things fast let's get something
cleared up
hours after the mini budgets last on
Friday last Friday did you celebrate
with the chancellor and a group of hedge
fund managers at a champagne reception
well look we often have Greek receptions
for donors in the conservative party in
fact these people should be lauded
because we don't have Public Funding of
political parties and these are people
who go up make money and donate to
political parties in the same way as
they do for the labor party and the
liberal Democrats in terms of that get
together it wasn't a get-together of
hedge fund managers it was actually
Britain's sort of leading entrepreneurs
yes I was there but it's the sort of
normal drumbeat of treasurer's events as
we call them in the conservative party
that we have all the time so there
weren't hedge fund managers there I mean
I'm sure there were or there was I think
one that I know of but in terms of the
rest of the people there lots of them
are people who've grown and start
businesses in fact the conversations I
had because it was my job before I did
this was people who work in the property
industry and what they were all saying
is they backed this government's drive
to create growth in the economy because
they they understand that you cannot
have a riding tide of rising tide of
prosperity that flows under every door
in this country without first creating
growth in the economy just want to look
at
look at this event the details from the
Sunday Times this morning so as the
markets crashed you acknowledge you were
at the multi-million pound Chelsea home
of the Tory donor along with other
donors including hedge funders
financiers many of whom may have made
money from the crash in the pound how is
that in any way appropriate well I'm not
sure that any of them did make money
from the crash in the pound and of
course you will know well the pounds
actually had its best week against the
dollar since 2020 if you look at the
close this week
aspersions against what people may or
may have not done whose name was
absolutely clear well I think people can
read the Times if they want to let's be
absolutely the home of somebody who has
acknowledged taking short positions on
the pound before absolutely clear this
is part of the normal drum beat of the
treasurer events within the conservative
party I was there there was no
confidential information that was
discussed it was a sort of a
get-together with some of Britain's
leading entrepreneurs who by the way we
should thank for creating growth in our
economy and be being on this drive to
Great Grove for every ordinary working
family in this country about our plans
foregrounding the economy how was the
chance of me does he drank champagne
well I'm not even sure that Chancellor
was drinking champagne I think he was
really a soft drink
um but um you know he was absolutely
clear that he has set out a path for
this country to create growth and the
reason we want to create growth is to
ensure that every family who is really
worried about things like their mortgage
rate would have been terrified if the
government hadn't have taken action on
energy bills people seem to forget that
just a few weeks ago we were talking
about four million businesses going bust
we were talking about tens of millions
of people losing their job we were
talking about the average household
having an energy bill of six thousand
pounds and now we're talking about 40
years
and we're talking about the bank of
England having to step in with a 65
billion pound bailout in order to stop
action the government has taken we have
cut on average a thousand pounds from
people's energies bills we have stopped
those millions of budgets going bust
look on the mortgage Market I understand
there is concern there is what would you
say to people who are really concerned
about the mortgage Market what are
irritated them is the government is
working both with the bank of England
and you saw that both the chancellor and
the Prime Minister have been working
with the obr and the bank of England to
ensure that we have stability in the
mortgage Market I don't believe that
will come I understand it's a
distressing time for people I understand
people are worried about their mortgage
but you know the government is working
to ensure that we have stability in that
market for every household in this
country now the article that's
underton's article also says the
chancellor gave insights as they put it
into future government spending cuts at
the event can you rule that out that he
made those comments well I certainly
didn't hear him make those comments um
have you asked him whether he did well I
was there so I listened to what he said
and what he talked about was his plan
for growth and what happened
categorically rule out that he didn't
have those conversations with anyone at
the event can you well I I don't
categoric rule it out because I didn't
hear every conversation but in terms of
what you asked me is the chancellor made
a statement or a speech talking about
future platens I can categorically rule
out that in that speech which is what I
heard we were all having our own
conversations of course we don't know
about the other conversations I mean you
don't know about conversations that
people have privately but I would ask
anyway like this so yeah I can
categorically rule out that in terms of
the address he made to the group of
people who were there as part of this
normal treasurer's event he did not give
any insight into future plans and I'm
sure in terms of his private
conversations he didn't give any insight
okay well let's look at the future plans
now are you going to cut spending to
bring public finances under control well
I think I think every household
understands that actually the reason
this government is going for growth is
because when you're struggling with your
household budget as many households are
you need to grow your personal household
budget in many cases people's pay
packets that's why we're going for
growth but you also need to manage your
expenditure and I don't think it's
unreasonable for the government to say
that the public sector should look at
its expenses in the same way that every
single household doing in this country
so that that means what we've heard from
the government is there's going to be a
drive to trim fat in terms of
government's expenditure
you use that word trim fact what do you
mean by trim fat where is that I think
everyone would accept that you know
there are efficiencies that can be found
in terms well I'll give you one example
you know the government has set out ways
in which is going to seek to recover the
bounce back loans many of which were
taken incorrectly we heard about the
whole scale forward and bounce back
loans that's a way we can recover how
much money is that though come on I mean
we're currently spending more on debt
interest payments than the entire
education budget you can have to find a
lot of fat well isn't that the reason
you that's the reason wants to grow the
economy because we didn't have a choice
let me answer the question then we have
a choice in front of us that we can keep
doing more of the same which is low
growth high taxes stagflation as it's
called or we can do what the government
has done which is try and create high
growth with a lower tax economy and the
reason to do that like every household
budget I've mentioned earlier the reason
to do that is if you have increasing
bills you have two choices you can
either cut the bills we cut your usage
or you can increase the amount of money
you have coming into the household that
is exactly what this government is
trying to do we are trying to increase
the amount of money coming in I.E grow
the economy we're not doing that as some
academic exercise we're doing because
it's right for every household in this
country while at the same time it will
be completely irresponsible of any
government not to say in the way that
households are finding Savings in their
budget it would be completely
irresponsible to say the public sector
or government Department should in some
way be immune from the decisions that
other households are having to take the
same way that people who are earning the
uh you know over 150 000 pounds a year
would be immune as they're getting a tax
cut well they are you're right they are
getting a tax cut but that's because
these are the entrepreneurs who drive
our economy but the more important thing
is that every single person let me
finish single person in work when their
payslip drops through the letterbox next
month will have had their National
Insurance go every single person who's
got an energy bill when their energy
bill drops through the letterbox this
month will see that the government has
capped prices to help with household
budgets and on the question of energy
bills as a percentage of GDP as a
government we have done more than any
other government in Europe to support
households and I think more than
anything else that shows how we're on
the side of working households I just
want to come in on the phrase that you
used about entrepreneurs who drive the
economy because I do think that a lot of
workers will find that quite offensive
to be completely honest you know you're
talking about they're very wealthy at
driving the economy but what about all
the other people who also drive the
economy and we know don't we from
analysis and it's only the people at the
top the richest people who are going to
benefit overall from the tax changes
that were introduced oh sorry we don't
know that from analysis I'm sorry that
is complete and other things
no I'm sorry that is simply incorrect so
let's put it on the record what we are
doing every single working person in
this country is going to see a cut in
their National Insurance next month well
sorry this month now and we also know
that the lower paid in this country as a
percentage of their income pay more in
National Insurance than higher earners
so in fact if there's a percentage of
increment is giving a bigger tax cut to
those lower earners than it is to the
top owner so I'm saying what you're
saying is simply incorrect you know
analysis is wrong and I am proud to be
part of a government that is
prioritizing tax cut for every worker in
this country not just those in the top
end a benefit's going to increase in
line with inflation well I'm not going
to come on here and make financial
statements that's a matter for the
chancellor and we will know in in due
course what is going to happen the
benefits
they would have got 19 pounds a week
more wouldn't they if the changes
announced by Rishi sunak to upgrade our
benefits in line with inflation it had
gone on how much given the inflation
pressures uh given you know what we've
seen with energy bills and she
acknowledged going up food inflation
double figures how much more a week do
you think people in benefits should be
able to have to really you know meet
that pressure what 19 pounds a week is
that too much 10 pounds a week I've
already said I won't make it's not for
me to make fiscal announcements in
relation to benefit
I know and understand and this
government knows and understands the
huge pressures that households are
facing and that's why we are pivoting to
grow the economy because in fact it's
only by growing the economy that we can
ensure that Britain can get a pay rise
we can ensure that people get really
decent public services that they rely on
and we can also ensure that we can
properly fund
both our public services but all the
other thing the government has to do
like you know we are you know seeing uh
threats from the East we need to
properly fund our Armed Forces we need
to properly fund the police we need to
properly fund our NHS that is the reason
we're growing the economy and it's for
every working household in this country
that we are doing that I just want to
have a look if I may at a chart this is
balances from the resolution Foundation
now this has shown the impact of the tax
changes in the budget and also if I know
you haven't come back to see it yeah if
you if you haven't confirmed that you
haven't confirmed at the expected
changes that we could say to Universal
Credit if their benefits do not rise in
line with inflation and you can see
there it is the very richest households
those on the right of the screen who are
going to be benefiting because of your
policy changes all those people on the
bottom impacted by the benefits those
are lower incomes negatively impacted is
that fair right I'm really sorry I can't
actually see the table what I go back
and say is that what we're doing for
every household in this country is
ensuring that they get a cut in their
tax bill next month when that payslip
drops to the letterbox or rise to our
email we've taken action on energy bills
which people will you know
we were going to lose tens of millions
of jobs in this country because of the
cost of energy for business we've taken
action that isn't now going to happen we
were getting to see inflation Peak at 19
predicted to Peak at 19 because we've
taken action on energy bills that now
won't happen inflation isn't some
academic figure that anchors and
economists and politicians and
journalists are talking about it has a
huge impact on every household in this
country that is why we're taking action
that is why we want to grow the economy
because we want every single household
to benefit from economic growth the
reporters the reports in the papers
today that Liz truss advised King
Charles not to attend the next climate
change Summit and he of course is
someone who has been quite supportive
should we say of the green agenda and
can you commit to The Net Zero carbon
emissions Target by 2050. the government
remains committed to The Net Zero Target
by 2050. so that's that so it's a change
so it's a yes okay thank you I
appreciate the clear answering that and
I just want to look a bit over overall
at the direction that you're taking
because in the telegraph you've got an
article today you say we're overturning
the tired economic Orthodoxy that's
prevailed for decades and are forging a
new direction for the country how big a
change is this
well it's rather to say how big it
changes I've been really clear what
we're doing we're seeking to create
growth in the economy I've been really
clear about why we're doing it we are
doing it to ensure that there is a
riding Rising spring tide of prosperity
that flows through every household in
this country that's what we're doing
that's why we're doing it and it's
because this government's values are on
the side of hard-working families across
the UK from you're quite there a new
direction for the country overtiming the
Orthodoxy that's prevailed for decades
so conservative administrations as well
as labor wants what's your mandate to
change what multiple governments have
done
well certainly the Prime Minister we
have a Monday on a 2019 Manifesto and
don't forget that 2019 Manifesto set out
two things it set out that we wouldn't
increase taxes and in fact we've
complied with that by reversing the
National Insurance rise it set out that
we would drive to create economic growth
and that's exactly what the prime
minister's doing we have an absolute
mandate from that Manifesto and we will
continue to deliver we really believe
you've got an apps like mandate
Manifesto there was nothing about
scrapping the 45p rate of tax Boris
Johnson promised the government wouldn't
go back to austerity he won a landslide
promising be expanding more nurses more
funding for schools more polices in
seats like yours absolutely right that
is why we're trying to create growth but
you're also talking about public
spending cuts you'll talk about trimming
the fat that is very difficult language
expect this government there's no such
thing as government money it's taxpayers
money but do you know I think do you
British acknowledge the key shift in the
the this government and what's going on
before you have said that you're about
to rip up the Orthodoxy of decades of
previous governments how can you say
that you had a mandate from the last
election well I think the British public
just to answer your question would
rightly expect this government when we
are spending their money it's not
government money it's their money would
rightly expect this government to make
the difficult Choice
I'm answering the question that I was
halfway through when you interrupted me
with this government to ensure that we
do not waste their money and we deliver
efficient Public Services look on the
Orthodoxy I don't think that it's a new
Orthodoxy for the conservative party to
say that it wants to deliver growth and
what we have seen over the last couple
of decades is a high tax low growth
economy and the truth is that if we are
going to change that not for the
government not for Bankers as you sought
to say earlier saying this is this is
government's motivation
households in this country
but it's the right motivation and in
truth tell households work people know
that when their bills arrive they can
either cut their consumption or they can
get higher salary or higher wages go out
there and get that new job what's the
approach the government is taking we are
saying
yes
so households can afford their bills as
well as the brilliant what we're doing
on energy bills you were talking about
what people expect to see from
government what the public would like
and let's have a look shall we uh you
got Paul from Thursday now I accept
there have been different polls but this
one from Thursday you got piles showing
labor has a 33 point lead
now when I move pulse fluctuate and I
know we're outside of an election
but this is quite jaw dropping you know
we've seen a labor League like this
since the 1990s it's not just this poll
opinion 19 point lead the prime
minister's net approval falling from -9
to minus 30 37 in a week that's worse
than Boris Johnson well let me tell you
also last Thursday there were two
violations in my constituency of
Rosendale and Darwin both of which we
won with an increased vote for the
conservative party the difference
between that poll and those by-elections
last week is it's a forced decision
where people have to make a choice and I
know and believe that when we get to
that general election when we have
delivered that growing economy when we
have ensured that the benefit is felt by
every household in this country that
it'll be a very different result than
shown in that snap Hole uh you know a
few days after the government has uh
mini fiscal event okay well that's
certainly uh interesting to see your
opinion and how different conservatives
are feeling at the minute it has been
I'll be honest quite difficult to find
people to talk to this conference
perhaps just a lot of them are staying
away or they don't necessarily feel that
they want to talk to the media right now
there are also reports that some
conservative MPS are even prepared to
vote against
the budget or the financial measures in
the budget if they did that would that
be treated as a vote of confidence would
they lose the word yes they would lose
their weight correct and so do you think
as well amid although that is a decision
for the chief whip but as far as I'm
concerned yes for doing that
um reports also saying that there are
people who are even thinking about
trying to find a way of in stating a new
leader bypassing the members having an
ability to have a say in having NPS to
decide what do you think the reaction to
that would be well I mean what I would
say to colleagues is we have a new prime
minister she has a mandate both from
colleagues on our membership she
absolutely has a plan for this country
that will create economic growth the
benefit of which will be felt by every
household in this country we need to get
on and Implement that plan we need to
unify behind that plan and add go out
there into our communities in Lancashire
across this country and Advocate our
core values of why we are doing this and
I'm sure that if we do that it will lead
ultimately to long-term election
um it's been really interesting talking
to T today I genuinely wasn't really
sure um you know how your sort of manner
would be your demeanor would be uh today
um you know you're someone who's always
you know advocated for leveling up right
you you've sought out people who may not
naturally be conservative voters you
kind of care about the communities
outside of London
how comfortable
are you personally with where the
conservative party is right now and the
way forward I'm absolutely comfortable
with that and I'll tell you why because
this idea that I read in the media that
people in communities across our United
Kingdom not just in the north but in the
southwest all over the country vote of
the conservatives because in some way
they wanted a labor government they
wanted a sort of labor light government
or whatever it may be in my experience
I'm not pollster but in my experience of
knocking on 14 000 doors over the summer
is just completely wrong what families
want is the government that is
absolutely determined to create growth
for them to increase their salary to
deliver world-class public services to
be on their side and that's what they
are getting with this government and on
the point of leveling up in the new
tax-free investment zones that the
government's announced around the
country we are going to see that agenda
turbocharged and we're going to see new
businesses opening creating those highly
paid secured jobs that's why I got into
politics I'm proud to be part of a
government that is going to deliver for
the community
and communities that I have the
privilege of calling home I've lived and
worked in the north my entire life I
know this government is going to deliver
from the north and I'm proud to be part
of that story this big gamble and growth
though isn't it it's all it's all or
nothing on growth how are you so sure
that you guys are right
in public as you've seen the polls are
wrong other concepts of MPS are wrong
many of the people in the markets are
wrong how confident are you well look
markets both react to government
statements and in my experience having
tracked this over a very long period
often overreact so let's see where the
markets are industry
they can overact I don't know if they
did in this case I'm not an economist
but let's see where the markets are in
six months time I think that's a far
better measure of the success of the
mini budget fiscal event but secondly
look in terms of creating that growth
let me tell you a little story my
sister-in-law went to hospital with her
father who lives in a care home who has
dementia he fell over and they had a
suspected broken hit he was in that a e
Department with dementia confused not
knowing where he was for 10 hours
waiting to see a doctor that is
completely unacceptable and the reason
this government wants to create growth
is to ensure that we have the money
coming into the country like it comes
into every household when you create
growth to give more money to the NHS to
deliver world-class Public Services
that's what people want to see that is
the what this government is going to do
and that's why I'm proud to be part of